this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] we're
back the joint is back
monday july the 11th the joint is
brought to you by express
vpn let me ask you something when you go
to the bathroom you always close the
door right
you want random passerbys looking on you
i don't think so so why would you let
people look in on what you're doing
online
using the internet without expressvpn is
like going to the bathroom and not
closing the door your internet service
provider sees every single website you
visit then they sell your information
the head company and tech giants
expressvpn puts a stop to this it
creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device the internet that's
your online activity won't be seen by
anybody
expressvpn works on all devices phones
laptops even routers so everyone who
shares your wi-fi can be protected even
if they don't have expressvpn
i use expressvpn on my phone anytime i
log in
to hope tell wi-fi and i love it using
expressvpn is as easy as closing the
bathroom door you just fire up the app
click on the button and you're protected
that's it
if you believe your online activity is
your business
secure yourself by visiting
expressvpn.com
joey again that's expressvpn.com
joey use my exclusive link to get three
extra months
for free that's how we're opening up a
monday on the joint that's
expressvpn.com
joey
go for it that's it [__] up cause it's
monday let's get this party started
[Music]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
what's happening you bad [__] i
missed you [__] it's the 11th of
july
it was a great [__] uh week to take
off you know
the holiday and [__] who wants to
[__] do podcast who wants to listen
to podcasts you guys are out with your
families so [__] it i didn't do it for a
week me and mike took the week off we
didn't do an album of the week we didn't
do [__]
but smoke [__] reefer eat and spend
time with the family which
is always a [__] good thing to
[__] do a couple people [__] died
while we were away jesus christ
you know but people are in shock about
it and i'm like hey guys they were
[__] old
james khan was 82 years old
it was time for james to go and it was
uh
paulie walnuts was 79 god bless the soul
[__] great character
funny guy stand-up guy listen guys i
never really knew
like some guy said to me today hey man
i'm sorry about paulie walnuts i was
like
i didn't know you know i met him one
time
uh we were shooting the soprano movie
and he was there and i said hello
yeah he was very cool he was already
older you know
we talked for maybe two minutes i'd love
to tell you i was friends with him and
we hung out and i did time with him but
that's not what happened then james khan
[__] and you know what's crazy about
james con man
i was noticing last week like we have a
short memory as [__] americans we
really do have a short [__] memory
like it's like we dismiss it was like
when the [__] cosby's
when uh
you know cosby got in trouble you know
nobody remembered how he [__] fired
lisa monet
for doing a [__] sex scene that
[__] filthy hypocrite never mind all
the rapes and all that [__] he was a
[__] hypocrite all the way through
but anyway
yeah he's he's a [__] uh he's out of
his [__] mind but that that's
that's not the [__] point we always
forget about
you know things with people projects
that they did when james khan died
everybody was talking about the
godfather and misery listen i love james
cotton the godfather don't get me wrong
but if you really want to see a james
khan movie and guys i love the thief i
think that's one of my top five movies i
love everything about james con that
movie but you [__] forget
brian's song
huh remember anybody i'll wait
[__]
nobody remembers brian's song it's about
[__] a black football player played
by billy d williams and james kahn i
think he played rocky blind don't
[__] quote me on this [__]
that movie i saw that movie when i was
like eight
dog i cried for a [__] week i'm gonna
cry just thinking about the [__]
movie it was such a great [__] movie
in the 70s
way before the godfather he did that
movie
it stayed with me for a couple [__]
days for different reasons and you guys
know i love movies this [__] they're
making today this ain't [__] movies
no more i was somewhere the other day
watching like my daughter's like look
dad the commercial for thor and i'm like
that doesn't look good at all like it
just
doesn't it just doesn't look good like
who the [__] you know you go see a movie
now and you [__] leave and like i saw
the adam sandler movie on uh
netflix
i forgot i saw it
there are so many movies the last two
years i just watch a movie and it blows
by you and then you watch like series
like the wire or
something and you're like okay this is
good [__] television but cinema
cinema has gone to the [__] wolves
guys
and
you know they don't make movies that you
go wow i got before i see another movie
i gotta think about what i just [__]
saw
i got to think about that scene and the
acting you know brian's song is is about
a pittsburgh two fit pittsburgh football
players
and
i don't know who i forget it's been a
long time guys i don't know who was
dying of cancer
one of them was dying of cancer and the
other one was his friend for all you
[__]
that love to cause racism problems
between black and white
watch that [__] movie
watch that [__] movie and
like i said i cried for a [__] week
when he died in that movie you [__]
cry
i mean i didn't know anything about that
i got me into football it got me into so
many things so yeah the thief was good
[__] godfather's great forget about
misery he's [__] great in misery
but as far as an acting movie that
jesus it [__] up my childhood i i
gotta be honest just thinking about it
i'm like god damn that movie [__] me
up like a year because it was the first
time and i like i had lost my dad
but it's that movie was so good i don't
know how to explain this to you it made
you experience a loss
like after that movie you're like [__]
i'm beat up and again some people are
like you know what i don't want to see
that type of movie joey no a lot of
people don't but you got to watch it
because it's definitely
up there with the [__] and the great
movies of our [__] time but check out
brian's song rest in peace
to my man james khan and even like
paulie like everybody said oh paulie
[__]
paulie did a movie with jan michael
vincent
when i was a kid i don't know and i
remembered paulie from that and then i
remember seeing him like goodfellas and
a couple of other [__] things
but uh
i go back with paulie like not
friendship wise but i go back with
paulie as a fan to maybe like the 80s i
think that was probably one if you look
that's probably one of his first
projects when he got out of [__] jail
he was in jail or whatever and that's
why he was an inspiration to me too
anybody who does some time
and does something with their life i
gotta tip my hat out to him because you
have no [__] idea how tough it is to
put it together when you get out of a
[__] joint but anyway what i want to
talk to you guys today was about [__]
you know i
i look at this podcast i look at the
church and look at what we've done over
the years and i really
don't talk a lot about social [__]
and it's not because i don't want to
talk about it or because it's a hot
potato i got to be honest with you i
don't know much about it
i i don't know much about it
when you're focusing when you're a [__]
up like me
and you want to focus on who's got money
you know who i remember when i knew like
when i do the album of the week and all
that [__] for patreon
you know i there's people like hey man
you know some weird stuff about music
because i was a loser
because i was a loser for years and i
read cream magazine and rolling stone
and you know i read all that [__] which
in the in the end of it at the end of
the day
it don't do dick for you it's just a
bunch of worthless information when you
go get a job nobody's going to ask you
where [__] randy rhodes was born
nobody's going to say to you what kind
of guitar did tony aiomi play you know
nobody's going to ask you what drum kit
[__] taylor used you know it doesn't
matter but we as americans
we want to be embroiled with all this
social consciousness and i love it i
love that you want to do it i will look
at some podcasts and i go i don't even
know how that person knows about those
topics how do they find time
to read up on all that [__] like my
whole journey
since i started the podcasting and doing
all this [__] was how to
get myself to be better me watching tv
or a trial isn't going gonna make me a
better person i never watched the oj
trial
i never watched the amber heard trial i
wouldn't watch that if you [__] paid
me i'd i could
you could have watched that trial dubbed
like i could have turned it off and i
could have done the [__] i couldn't
tell you what they did to each other
[__] on the bed
that's hollywood that's the hollywood
dirt merchants all the money in the
world can't buy [__] class and you
people are in shock
you people like oh my god they live
these these people are the nastiest
[__]
you've ever met in your life because
they're so rich they've forgotten how to
do things for themselves whether it's
cut their toenails whether it's clean a
[__] toilet you know i think a [__]
and when i take a [__] i [__] up those
[__] toilets
you know what who cleans those toilets
me my wife tells me you better clean
that [__] [__] toilet those people
have never [__] they've never cleaned
the toilet
so the reality is [__] so gone guys
i don't i didn't watch a minute of that
trial and i can tell you just from what
people told me
what
you know what the [__] was going on it's
no shock to a guy like me because i've
heard all those things you don't hear
those things
you live off what you read off people
magazine or what people say on tv shows
and [__] but when you're out there
living you catch different things from
people people like if you go shoot a
movie
an actor came in last week like that
that was talking we were talking about
comics
when i was doing the road all those
years by myself
you know some weeks i went out with
rogan some weeks i went up by myself
when i was doing the robot myself
i noticed something [__] hilarious
and any time you got to a club and the
wait staff was pissed off on a tuesday
it's because two things
either shriek was there what was his
name shriek shrek
the guy from [__] that show that
stabbed somebody you know uh
sheik shrek
i don't know what the [__] kid's name
is he just died recently at cancer
he was on a tv show
with all the mario lopez and all those
[__] kids when they were younger and
they didn't screech
screech that [__] worthless penguin
yeah he died about a year ago during the
[__] pandemic when i was on the road
screech was causing [__] havoc on the
road havoc every got him time i got to a
club and they will screech was there i'm
like god damn it the staff is pissed the
managers pissed the people at the hotel
was pissed there's two comics that when
you went in after them
the [__] wait staff was pissed
screech and [__] angel salazar who i
love angel's one of my dogs
i hope he's doing well
screech [__] drove everybody so
[__] crazy
so when you got to a comedy club they
it's like comics don't when you live in
l.a you see a comic at the store you see
a comic at the improv you see a comic at
the live factory you really don't know
what's going on with them
it's when you go on the road that when
you get to a club uh you go who was here
last week and they'll tell you and
they're like oh
that [__] guy brought in [__]
hookers and you know so anything you do
is never really a secret the club owners
tell you everything oh he came here he
was eating [__] mushroom you know and
they tell you things very innocently but
they don't know at the same time they're
spreading [__] rumors
because now these comics go back to l.a
and go hey you know what the [__]
club owner told me in st louis that when
this comic was there he was taking it in
the ass he talks all that [__] about
being married you have no [__] idea
but my point is
when you go on a set
it's the same thing
they shoot the big stars out the
principles first
so when you get on a set yeah you might
have a day with ray liotta you might
have a day with james khan whatever but
all those stars are shot out early
so when you get there by the time a
bum like me gets there
to shoot
they're telling you all these little
things this guy [__] his pants
this guy's [__] feet smell this guy
smelt like pee
this guy didn't shower and you're like
these guys are [__] rich
millionaires i mean some of these actors
come on the set in the morning without
showering
nothing they go not brushing their teeth
not combing their hair they go on a set
and they're such big stars that people
just dress them up
it's crazy i've heard stories where
actors walk on with no teeth
[__] black eyes and they come on an
hour later looking like [__] johnny
velvac they're [__] sharp
their teeth are in you know everything's
in but that's not what do you hear about
all the creepy [__] they did like they
brought a [__] kid to the set you
know you hear all this [__]
and you're like you know what i wish i
didn't hear it so i never really got
into none of that [__] i didn't really
care you hear stuff yeah whatever blah
but with like amber heard and all this
what was another case that just [__]
happened i don't know any of this stuff
guys so i'm sorry if my podcast is
short-handed
in that department i don't like talking
about [__] i don't know
i'm not gonna sit here and talk to you
[__] about parachutes i don't
know anything about [__] parachutes
you know what i'm saying but the reason
why i'm talking about this is
a couple weeks ago before the break i
was shocked by this guys i mean
one thing i do like is the law
i love
watching like
reading about cases and stuff like that
i told somebody a couple weeks ago when
i lived here in 85 84
at night when i got out of work i would
go to this [__] deli on 30th street
and buy a [__]
sandwich like a
[__] italian hero sandwiches 1985-84
and i would go downtown where they shoot
law and order
and i would just sit in courtrooms
i would go to court with a [__] bag
of wise potato chips a [__] hoagie
and a [__] 16 ounce coke and i would
sit there till two in the morning
watching night court all the people that
they were bringing in for [__]
drinking or vagrancy or doing coke in a
club or fist fighting i would sit there
for hours i'd love that type of [__]
that's an education going to court
especially at that time
i was thinking i was going to be an
attorney
i don't know how the [__] i was going to
pull it off with no high school diploma
and a criminal background but that was
what i was [__] going for
so
i i didn't know what was going on or
anything with this trial you know i'm
busy trying to get back into stand-up
and raising my daughter and i heard that
[__] jay-z what not jay-z bite my
tongue i heard that r kelly got 30
[__] years
so i i just
for two days i didn't really pay who
gives a [__] about r kelly i don't
you know so i'm just for 30 years i give
a [__] about when somebody gets 30 years
something ain't right like mike tyson
got six years seven years for the rape
the uh accused rape he never raped
nobody he got seven years for that you
know that's the slap on the [__]
wrist you know
that was looking at nine years for
kidnapping uh violent uh kidnapping two
violent all the way plead guilty to that
that's nine [__] years you know after
you get out at seven [__] years with
good behavior whatever
but i didn't know what r kelly had done
i knew he [__] slept with underage
girls but that's where it ended even
that
when r kelly started coming back up a
couple years ago
like people were in shock oh my god he
dates underage girls hello where the
[__] were you in 1993 when he was dating
[__] elia when he married lea when
she was 14. anybody who sees that
[__] girl knows
she's four look at the [__] pictures
of her you're like that's a [__] girl
you know a couple weeks i went to a
barbecue around the corner
maybe uh two like when i got back from
[__] birch thing i think i don't know
and i'm at the pool and my daughter's in
the pool a bunch of other girls her age
they're nine maybe ten
they're running around you know i'm
saying so i'm checking on them i'm
talking to these parents over here and
i'm checking on the girls and there's a
couple boys in there too but one of the
things the baby should have slipped in
and she's like 24. and she went up with
like a eenie beanie weeny [__] bikini
so i'm sitting there and i'm talking to
the parents and also i go to check on
the girls
and i see this girl and i didn't see her
walk in so i'm like holy [__] katie's
getting big because the biggest kid out
of the group is this girl named katie
and i look at him like holy [__]
katie's getting big she's got some
[__] body for a 12 year old and then
i it was that kaden they're like no
that's the baby so i go holy [__] i got
all confused by watching and then
i looked at it for a couple minutes and
i know the baby says she's really sweet
i know her and her boyfriend
i asked her on the way out can i ask you
a question how old are you and she goes
i'm 24.
i told my wife that i go you know
kristin might be 24
but
she's a girl
like when i saw she's a girl
that's a kid
that that
you know i couldn't even talk to that
girl like i i'd say hello to her and
[__] she asked me about my daughter
whatever we talk but
what would i say to her in a club or
something like that and i thought about
a friend of mine that was not really a
friend he's an acquaintance from l.a he
was 59
and his wife was 21.
and it was it just didn't work for me
guys
i'm sorry when he told me that and she
came to the office to [__] rip my
[__] uh
podcast office i
i could not believe it i i looked at
this girl yeah i looked at this girl and
i'm like
24. i mean that's a [__] girl
so all this [__] about age like 18
18 never worked for me
like i hear all these stories about
comics with young girls whatever yeah
these girls are [__] 19
they're [__] 18 whatever you know i
don't know i don't know some guys like
younger girls if you hear any of my
stories i always like older women anyway
when i was 19 i dated a 27 year old and
when i was 14 i was trying to hit on a
40 year old [__] milf so
but just just the fact that you would
take that girl bring her home
and try to [__] and then start a
relationship with her
i mean who benefits from this [__]
relationship
you do as a [__] 40 or 50 year old
big
but that girl was scarred for life i
know from looking at my dick i wouldn't
show my dick at this age
to anybody you understand me the days of
sucking uncle joey's dick have long been
gone
i don't want to show my dick to anybody
it's been years
since anybody's seen my dick i showed
you my ball sack
and during the comedy store [__] uh
benefit and you guys had to go to
therapy can you imagine this i show you
the whole [__] package i mean i know
this going in like i don't ever [__]
like these girls so
they all [__] came to me at one shot
that week i'm like who would date that
[__]
young girl like that that's over anybody
who's over 40 to date that girl you're a
[__] sack of [__] don't tell me that
it's love it ain't [__] love
it's perversion so
the other night i'm like what the [__]
could you
i didn't really know i thought he just
slept with an underage girl holy [__] so
yeah and i went on netflix
that's what i thought i thought he slept
with a couple of 16 year olds that's
what i thought uh
r kelly had done i really don't know
anything about his life guys i was busy
doing stand-up
you understand me when you're when
you're trying to move up a [__] notch
in your life you got to sacrifice that
[__] that shit's not going to put any
money in your pocket it's not going to
help you to achieve your goal at any
[__] cost so
the other night i'm smoking a couple
numbers i'm stoned and i'm watching
netflix and there's nothing on and it
says surviving r kelly now i know that
show came out like two years ago or
whatever and people were talking about
how nasty he was
guys i watched five [__] episodes one
night and i had to turn that
[__] [__] off
like it was so
[__] disturbing
like remember i told you guys that i
moved to jersey one of the main reasons
i moved to jersey
was just to get my daughter out of that
world
because [__] rolls downhill my friend
and those parents that [__] rolls
downhill to those kids and i had to get
her the [__] out of that it just
certain things i had to do to get the
[__] out of that for certain reasons i
can't put my finger on it it was just
time to leave but
after i watched that i turned off the
fifth maybe the fourth episode the fifth
episode i can't watch this anymore
now i gotta prepare to how to get
my little girl prepared
for this stupidity because
you know all the girls have the same
story i mean this [__] was
hanging out of the high school
he was hanging
out
at a [__] high school now let me tell
you something guys
i quit high school in 1981
i think i went up there like once or
twice to meet friends at the school
and i felt like [__] just going up there
like what there's a ton of kids that
would quit school and hang out at school
afterwards like look at me i quit school
you know what you're a [__] loser you
quit school
at least go [__] work you know
i went up there like twice to meet
friends like at 2 30 and [__] and i'm
like this ain't from me
once you're out of that school you're
out at school there's no reason to go up
there and hang out in fact
nothing bothers me more about north
bergen that there's still guys
my age walking around with football
jackets on
that's not [__] good that's not good
it's time to move the [__] on you know
but uh i watched this [__] thing and
it was just
disturbing to all al
what this guy was doing i mean this guy
he was married for a while he would make
her live in the room and bring other
women to the house
and kids and [__] but he had a 12
year old girl of
dawg some [__] chick that he made a
video with
i don't know
she caught him [__] somebody under
the bed there's a [__] in the video
and [__] i don't [__] know guys i
just saw it on
i haven't watched mdv it's in 1994 since
kurt cobain got [__]
since he is himself i don't know what
the [__] is going on in the musical
world
this [__] did a video with a
girl and then she came back with a 12
year old niece
to meet jay-z up jay-z i keep saying
jay-z i'm not gonna get sued for [__]
slander i love jay-z
jay-z didn't molest no 16-year-old but
[__]
so she he had an adult girl that's
[__] beautiful his sister
and he did a video with her and then i
don't know in time the girl brought a
her niece and a rapper
12 years old the [__] kid had skills
the kid could [__] rap so they
figured they were on to something so
you know
she never thought much about it and
that's who he made the video with a
piston in her mouth and [__]
he made a [__] video with a girl i
did not know this guy so
i know to you you guys know this [__] i
have no idea and he pissed on this girl
and i watched all these episodes like
they were [__] making fun of him on
chappelle
chappelle had like a big gallon of piss
and he was just bringing on war i mean
it's [__] crazy pissed in the girl's
mouth he pissed on her
this is [__] then he made a video and
somebody saw the video so they made
duplicate copies of it and it's called
like uh [__] whatever r kelly sex
tape volume one i didn't know about this
[__]
and he [__] put the girl out there
and then he met him while he was on
trial he met a girl that was 14
and put her and he got these girls
pregnant and he would you know guys i i
i could see you know like
what's the little chubby kardashian the
one i like you know
there's like what's her name courtney
and then there's the [__]
what's the one that made the sex tape
kim so kim made the sex tape she's just
a [__] animal they should just put
her in a cage guys she's just a [__]
animal and they just came out that the
mother set up the whole animals like i
told you l.a
animals anything for success animals
what mother
would make her daughter do a [__] sex
tape and listen
welcome to la anyway
[__] the chubby one the chubby one is
very sweet
very cute she's tried everything to be
like her sister don't take you it don't
take you to be a fortune telling know
what's going on that kardashian house
the chubby one is the cutest one she's
sweet she's loving but you know what
everybody cheats on
like everybody cheats hannah every
brother in the world has cheated on her
you know i don't know if she doesn't
give good head i don't know if she
doesn't stick a finger i don't know what
the [__] she doesn't do right but
everybody cheats on her you know what
guys when a guy cheats on you that's not
a sex crime when a guy cheats on you
with some [__] chick at a club it is
what it is you know i'm saying it's not
a [__]
sex crime but this [__] guy
jesus
jesus he was making the fifth the 17
year old go down on the 14 year old and
i just i was [__] in shock guys
listen guys listen you know we've all
done our drugs we've all liked to get
our dick sucked we all like to jump up
and down but to [__]
piss on somebody like
and just take these little girls and you
could see
what really concerned me about my
daughter was like
these were 15 year old girls listen when
i was a kid when i was 17 i had a crush
on pat bennett
okay i just had a crush on pat bennett
right we all have a crush on somebody
some people like [__] uh the chick
from fleetwood mac
so we all have a crush on somebody
you know did i go see pat benatar a few
times yeah i went to see peppa did i
chase her down for an autograph or a
[__] picture or give her a hug no i
did something dumber when pat bennett
was getting married in 1983 on mtv mtv
was going to have a wedding for her in
hawaii
and in those days i don't know you
you're young mike but
in the days of mtv mtv would do uh
raffles every month one of the raffles
was van halen coming to your house to
play in your backyard
with like 20 000 cases of beer and [__]
every
summer every couple months they had some
type of raffle you know
and
right before i left in april of 83
mtv had a f i was going through a rough
patch like you know when you have bad
luck like it don't stop but it was it
wasn't society's bad luck it was me
being the kiss of death like i was
[__] bad luck
so everything i touched turned to [__]
so now i turned on mtv one day and
[__] pat benatar's getting married to
that [__] guitar play and i'm like
what the [__] is going on here that's it
that ain't happening we're going to
hawaii and we're boycotting the [__]
marriage right
but i'm a broke dick i ain't even got
money to go to newark how am i gonna get
the [__] in hawaii right so me and my
buddies came up with a scam we went out
and we bought every [__] postcard
blank postcard that we could
and we made put the mtv address 125th
avenue
new york new york
zero two five i'm still a geek i still
remember all that [__] and you have to
put down like you know pat benatar
contest i want to enter
guys
i put at least 200 in a mailbox every
day
i had people helping me i had people
mailing them from different mailboxes
somebody said spread them around i mean
i was going insane i was going to hawaii
to [__] step up to the pump to tell
neil geraldo to [__] himself
he was lucky if we didn't throw a
beating on him we were going to [__]
drag him by his [__] little
glamour guitar and take pat benatar from
him it's a [__] wild fantasy
but
you know i'm an idiot
the coke is [__]
pushing the dream a little bit so what
do i do i [__] send
i don't know how many [__] postcards
to pat benatar to mtv
they announced the winners on mtv i
didn't win third place like i think like
fifth place is like like a [__]
picture of pat i would be happy with a
picture of pat i must have sent ten guys
a stack of those cards and i won
nothing
but
i didn't chase her down to hawaii and
hook up with her or try to hook up with
her it's really sad that these girls
were young kids
and they were going to the [__]
courthouses
you know he would invite him over tell
him they could sing
come over and sing the girl would sing
and they tell the girl take your [__]
clothes off you're [__] sucking it's
it's
it's uh
that's worse than this that that's worse
than somebody cheating on you you know
what i'm saying and when the girls told
you the story
like at first they were trying to keep
it together like how cool they were like
you know that this is something that
just happened in their life
and it's like me talking to you about
kidnapping or
something that happened to me but then
after a while you could see that they
just break down
you know he knocked him up he made him
get abortions
he made them [__] he just put them he
put these girls
through the health of emotions i mean if
he did it to 15 girls i'll be surprised
if four of them don't ice themselves you
don't come back from that at a young age
like that
you know when you put on you porn or
whatever the [__] you guys watch and you
see those [__] chicks with their
eyes spread out or you know whatever the
[__] they're doing they're not all there
and they didn't get there by getting hit
in the head by somebody that's by
somebody inflicting [__] trauma and
sexual abuse constantly since they were
little kids they didn't [__] know it
and they grew i grew up with one of
those girls that
you could just ask her like do you mind
sucking my dick no get in the car
she was 19 20 you know she just recently
died three years ago but i grew up with
this girl that
something was not right there
and yeah you got your dick sick from her
one time
but if you love your mother and you have
any [__] idea what's going on with
mental health you look at this girl and
say you know what
me getting her to suck my dick isn't
that big of a [__] deal anybody can
do it i mean obviously there's something
wrong with the [__] girl
that blonde that you see at [__]
macy's
that's hotter than [__] the one that you
went over everybody's trying to hit on
and nobody get nowhere that's a check
you want to convince to suck your dick
not once but twice cause you got to work
for that [__] that's a you got
to be a salesman you got to show up with
flowers and [__]
planes and say i love you you know the
[__] planes that drag this [__] i
love you whatever the [__]
but uh yeah
guys i just i was [__] blown away man
so sometimes i'm happy i don't pay
attention
to [__] what's going on because i
can't deal with i really that's just
this [__] now he has to go to
another state
and get sentenced again i mean it's all
going to go concurrent but he'll never
[__] see the he'll never see daylight
again this [__] guy and i think he
was suing the court because they put him
on
suicide watch and she listen
they they put you in suicide watch
sometimes for your suicide but sometimes
they put you in that suicide watch you
don't get [__] killed
that's the bottom line i've been to
[__] jail they have a section for the
rats like protective custody they have
that but guess what
those [__] eat so they'll try
to poison you you know what i'm saying
like those that suicide watch they watch
[__] everything they watch what goes
in what goes out
so
you know maybe it's for his protection
i mean he and all that [__] he did
i mean i could see if he did it the
white chicks you know to get back from
what's what's the thing black people are
looking for they're looking for a
payment
reparation i can see if you're gonna
[__] a bunch of white chicks and then go
to court and just say reformations
whatever the [__] it is
but he did it all to his own kind he did
it all to sisters man
all the young sisters and you know what
these young sisters don't
they don't catch a break
you know if you know anything about the
ghettos and stuff like that sexual
whatever is big in those [__]
communities all those kids come home
they grow up with a [__] story you
know a drunk uncle whatever the [__] it
was somebody who wasn't paying attention
to him anyway
enough with the [__] pedophilia talk
i just didn't know
that this [__] was going on i didn't
know they could throw somebody in jail
for having sex
30 [__] years i could see if he i
don't know if he raped him i don't know
what he did i know he held them against
their will they were touching on that
some parents didn't see their daughters
for two [__] years
he would make them you couldn't eat he
would starve them
he would starve the girls he would
[__]
you had to ask him permission to use the
bathroom
you had to ask him permission to eat
girls this is why this is why you got to
be careful and watch your back at all
times you don't know what you're falling
into you know now i know that there's uh
i know what they were talking about the
other day there's a defamation case not
you know this made it great for guys
this was an embarrassing victory
whatever the victory was and the [__]
uh amber heard
johnny depp thing they're both [__]
embarrassing and they both should be
[__] ashamed of themselves
but now they're starting to talk about
that there's another case coming up
my boy [__] uh crazy boy
you know uh
what's the guy that's [__] nuts he
dated the girl from the hbo show and she
left him he said he would put razor
blades and a [__] and all that [__]
what's that you know our boy that
the freak show whatever the freak show
you know
welcome to the
[Music]
yeah that poor girl
she's gonna go in there and say how she
when you date marilyn manson when you
think he's gonna bring your [__]
dozen roses
he's gonna bring you a [__] roses
mixed with barbed wire to show up shove
up your [__] [__] as a sex act so
if you're going over there to hold hands
you gotta know the animal that you're
[__] dealing with after goddamn time
so whatever
so uh the other thing i want to talk to
you about that i did on the [__]
vacation that
guys i [__] loved this [__] for years
and
i did it as a hobby when i first
was doing comedy like i did
a hobby i did it all my [__] life
i was just a geek about it i'm the type
of guy that when i read something i
could tell in the first 10 pages
if i'm gonna like this book or not a lot
of people like ah you don't like that
book man
i could tell in the first ten i give a
book like three or four chapters and if
it don't grab me it's not for me if it's
one of these books where i gotta wait
for it to bust open it's not gonna work
for me you know
so the last two years i was a little
[__] slippery and [__] my mind wasn't
working right you know i was trying to
write jokes
and i was just trying to write after i
wrote the book with uh erica you know we
wrote it together
i've been trying to [__] focus on [__]
and that's what was going on with me the
last couple weeks that
i couldn't uh
write jokes like i was like what the
[__] is going on like i don't even know
how to write a [__] joke i downloaded
some i went online and i
you know just looked up joke writing and
and i was still struggling and all those
shows i was doing
i was having a rough time i was
having a rough time doing over 15
minutes and then when i went on the
birth door
being up on stage loosened a lot of [__]
and i started at least doing old jokes
it's not what i wanted to do
but at least i was starting to remember
the old jokes i'm like this is good my
mind
my mind is getting [__] uh exercised
again
but it was father's day and uh
my wife got me some books
about two months ago i went to barnes
and nobles with him in freehold and i
just bought a [__] book like i uh
i just bought a book about the new
jersey on the world
and i [__] read the thing in like
four days i was like all right because
when i tried to read the judas priest
book the rob halford book
it was a great read but after sucking
dick and [__] people in the ass and
busting [__] you could just take so
much of that but i couldn't focus on him
but guess what when i finish this book
i'm gonna start reading the judas
priests once again because i'm having
eric roach on next week
and we were talking about that i didn't
hear from him over gay pride month
that i wanted to hear some stories of
some busted [__] and some [__] uh
you know
i hadn't heard from him so we're gonna
have him on but anyway my wife got me a
[__] book it's crazy i spoke to tj
english and he says he's coming out with
a new book august 16th or something like
that so i go send me the book
so i could read it and when you get on
the podcast at least i'll know it's
called like dangerous rhythms or
something like that
so he sent me the book and right as i
was about to read it i was going to take
it with me on the birth tour
so yeah you have all this [__] dead
time but in fact i took this other book
of me my wife got me uh
the biggie small story or something like
that the story of biggie small some new
book that came out
and she got me this book here
the [__] westies by tj english
holy
[__]
when this book first came out i read it
and the copy that i had
for years i saved this book and i gave
it to joe rogan joe rogan and me talked
about this book for [__] years in
fact when he had tj english on this
podcast joe kept trying to push this
book like the westies he wrote the
westies he wrote the westies this
if you've never had it and it's funny
i'm doing the sony theater is on 46th
and 8th
westies ran on 48th and 10th and [__]
down towards the hudson [__]
river if you don't know who the westies
are
it's a book about these [__] 13 irish
guys did you ever hear them
it's a book about these 13 irish guys
in the west side they ran hell's kitchen
there was a guy mickey featherstone who
ran it first or something like that
they [__] shot him this book
will
leave you like what the [__] am i
reading these guys were so tough and i
knew all this stuff already it was just
great to read it all over again
these guys are so tough
13 of them that the mafia had to go talk
to them
like they didn't go up to brooklyn or
the bronx the mafia had to go to the
west side and talk to them
paul castellano all of them had to go
talk to them
there was 13 of these [__]
maybe 15 11 who the [__] knows it was a
handful and these guys were kidnapping
mafia bookshop loan sharks
killing them and then collecting their
debts
that's like [__] unheard of now
in all your knowledge you're like yeah
the mob the mob the mob didn't know what
to do with these [__] because
they didn't give a [__]
they were shooting they were doing drugs
they were they were [__] uh skinning
people alive these [__] were
the first ones that were
like uh chopping people up they took
their hands off and their heads and then
they had their body and they [__]
buried the body
this book is so [__] good but the the
reason why i like this book so much is
because it opens up 20 other [__]
avenues
i don't know if you saw the movie
sleepers
they were westies those four guys were
westies that's why when lorenzo
carcatera wrote that book they were
gonna [__] kill him because these are
like tough guys they're gangsters on the
upper west side now you're telling
people that we went to jail and got
raped what the [__] are you saying so
that movie uh
the other movie that made with sean penn
that he did with uh
who's the greatest actor of all [__]
time the white dude gary oldham
holy [__]
state of grace state of grace is a movie
that came out
maybe 91
90 89
it's about the westies how they lived on
the west side but they moved to [__]
uh northern new jersey and they were
going to the west side every day and it
was a it's like an off movie about sean
penn [__]
was original with them he grew up with
them but then he went away
john turturro's in that movie great
[__] movie state of grace and then he
comes back 20 years later and now all
these young irish guys are [__]
gangsters he comes back as a cop anyway
it's a good [__] but it ties all this
[__] together so if you read this book
it's cheap uh the reason why i took it
out today because i want to tell you
something it's cheap the inside new
york's irish mob
includes new and updated material
tj [__] english great [__]
book but it's interesting as [__]
these were the guys when you see
sleepers that they walked into the bar
and the guys are talking about politics
and the guy goes listen go over there
send them a drink on me but tell them no
[__] politics and no religion in this
bar then they get up and shoot kevin
bacon right in the [__] head
tremendous
this is the [__] i [__] live for you
understand me but we're back [__]
last week my stand-up set
was [__] tremendous i have to be
honest with you guys all the other [__]
i did bert i started coming alive
atlantic city if you saw me uh yeah
whatever the guest spots i did at uncle
vinnie's yeah whatever
bert's uh bristol
i did okay and [__] whatever bristol
i did okay
and uh atlanta i did a little [__]
better but nothing came together for me
and for you stand up sort of young and
want to know what the [__] happening
i'll tell you what's happening
and now for a word from my sponsor
better help listen you got to take care
of your mind you spend a lot of time
taking care of your skin your hair your
teeth but you never really think about
your brain
you have to take care of your brain
because it affects how you experience
life investing time and energy and
mental health is crucial happiness
eating right working out getting plenty
of sleep there good start but there's no
substitute for talk therapy listen
better help makes online therapy
accessible convenient and affordable why
is therapy important i don't know it
helped me dana did great work with me
she gave me exercises to do we spoke
every week better help is online therapy
that offers video phone and chat therapy
sessions listen there's no stigma with
it guys
we all gotta look at this guy sean
mendez he had to cancel three weeks of
his tour he said it was overwhelmed
that guy's gonna go talk to somebody
hopefully it's better help you can
choose to either see someone on camera
or not and it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy you could be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours what i'm going to do for you joint
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com
shoei again that's betterhelp.com
joey i'm going to give you a 10 off
your first month that's how we're
rolling with better help contact better
help and start your therapy right now
and i've done this a lot in my life and
it's not a good thing to do do not worry
about this this is why when people tell
me they're thinking about doing stand up
but they have to write material i tell
them not to worry about the material i
go for right now i just like if you pay
if you came to me and said joy i want
you to be my stand-up coach
all right i want you to take me from
point a to point z
how do i do this
i'd say to you number one just get on
stage but joey let me get some material
no material
i want you to get on stage let's do that
let's just get that out of the [__]
way
let's get on [__] stage you're gonna
stay out there for three minutes i'm
gonna stay there with a marksman
repeater you know what a marksman repeat
is it's a [__] bb gun and it shoots
darts bbs and [__] pellets and i will
[__] shoot you with something if you
get off that stage before three minutes
i want you to experience that and i want
you to [__] feel it right
once you get off stage and you come to
me and go joey that was great i want to
do it again i'm gonna tell you go up
there again tomorrow night but joey i
got no material do what you did tonight
talk about your cat talk about your
mother talk about your father's [__]
fungi toenail i don't give a [__] what
the [__] you talking about after you do
like two or three times now i want you
to start
maybe maybe
when i came back this time i did rule
number one i did a mistake guys and i'm
okay with it
i focused on the words
i was focusing too much on the words and
then i would give up i would open up my
notebook outline
try to write in the daytime nothing
would happen i'd smoke some pot i would
sit there you know when you write if you
look at any of those writing books they
tell you to put away a certain amount of
time
for me it's an hour and a half after an
hour and a half my back starts to
[__] hurt guys i can't sit there you
gotta get the [__] up and out put a
timer next to you and sit there for that
hour and a half
and you write and you're not gonna get
the best jokes in the world but keep
writing if you do that
20 [__] times 20 days in a row
start with an hour you're gonna sit down
for one [__] hour every day okay this
is mitch hedberg the saint joey diaz
this is me talking to mitch hedberg all
those years and him telling me how he
did it mitch hedberg had those [__]
jokes not because he was doing drugs and
smoking pot
mitch hedberg took it a [__] area
even deeper than us mitch would sit down
for three hours
no phone no music no radio
three hours take off for an hour two
hours and that was it mitch was writing
five hours a [__] day guys
even in the heart of his [__]
addictions and [__] i mean i didn't talk
to him the last year of his life
but i know for a fact that [__]
was writing five hours a day i gotta
tell you something if i'm writing five
hours a day i'm gonna be the best
[__] stand-up in the world because i
could sit for an hour and a half
and when you write for an hour and a
half it's gonna for the first week
you're not gonna [__] nothing's gonna
come anything out
you're gonna keep doing it but then
you're gonna notice something
at the end of it let's say you say
joey i'm going to do it for an hour i
guarantee you
after a week at the 50-minute mark
you're going to start writing jokes
you're going to start writing them
you're going to see this
it's just going to one joke here one
joke there it's going to be a lot better
than once and this is what i'm saying to
you if you don't dedicate that window
and i'm talking to you about mitch
hedberg i'm talking to you this is not
what i did this is why i'm a mutt and
i'm sitting at home in the studio
the dave chappelles those guys that are
up there this is what you want to do
they write five six hours a day and then
they write on [__] stage while
they're up there and i did this for a
long time also i'm not saying i just did
it a different way
i do a lot better writing on stage and
in my notebook everybody has their own
different way and in time you'll figure
out what works for you i don't know how
it works musicians i don't know if they
do the music first or the [__] words
first i don't know that's not what i'm
here for
but for stand up you write then you take
it up to that stage that night you make
adjustments my mistake was i was
focusing too much on the [__] words
i was focusing too much on the words and
i'm like you know what
so when i went down uncle vinnie's last
week that was the same day i went to the
beach
do you really think
i would ever go to a beach on the day i
had a show to do 40 minutes
[Music]
if that was ten years ago i would have
been home all day writing
sweating preparing
it didn't [__] matter to me
i did not give a [__]
i went to the beach i didn't look at a
notebook
until i got home about six o'clock i
just made some notes that i wanted to
move this around and there was maybe
four things on the notebook and let me
tell you something
i did that 40 45 minutes i only covered
one of those things that i read in a
notebook
always remember before you go on stage
if you look at your notebook and you
look over the notes
every time you go over the notes whether
it's three times or two times you're up
in your percentages to do a lot better
just going through your notebook not
writing just going through it making
little adjustments even though tonight
i'm going to move that here boom stop
right there but i got to tell you
something i went down there wednesday
night and i held no [__] prisoners
i didn't think about the words the jokes
i had on paper
didn't even come out i didn't do the
[__] action part bit i didn't do
anything
there was one bit i wanted to try you
know when people
get the transgender surgery where they
get the dick from is there like a dick
factory that makes dick for transgender
people like hold on he gets a size 11
they rip it i just wanted to try all
that stupid [__] and guess what
it worked guys i came back home i was
like holy [__]
lee called me the next day and somebody
who one of my friends was at the show
and he goes joey that's the best i've
seen you in a long time ago i'm gonna
tell you what
and this is the best you are gonna see
me
i don't give a [__] about a netflix
special
i don't give a [__] about a special
i don't give a [__] about what an agent
or a booking agent says to me
i don't give a [__] if you cancel me
because i got nothing that you could
take from me nothing you could cancel me
for a show whatever
that's the best position to be
when you want to do stand-up
think about it i don't want to do
anything i don't want to do an hbo
special i can give a frenchman's [__]
about
the tonight show any of that [__] i'm 60
years old it's a hobby for me i'm
[__] really good at it
and i'm gonna keep [__] doing it and
i don't give a [__] it doesn't matter
nobody can this is the this is joey diaz
on
there's nothing you could take from me
when you lose a sponsor who gives a [__]
they come and they [__] go
who the [__] i'm saying so
this is the best i'm ever gonna be i got
a couple shows this summer and uncle
vinnie's i gotta show an asberry i got a
show in the city you know 15-minute
spots whatever i'm gonna take my time
i'm gonna have a great [__] time this
summer and guess what when we start that
residency september 17th i think it's
october 10th
whatever i'm gonna be in such [__]
great shape and i'm excited for this i
don't have to do anything i don't give a
[__] what comes out of my mouth i don't
give a [__] about what you got to say
whether you're uncomfortable whether
you're offended none of that [__] even
works for me let me tell you something i
did such a great show the other night
nobody was offended
and i was talking about some wild [__]
you just gotta explain yourself more you
just gotta write the joke
tell the joke not write the joke tell
the joke
explain the joke and tell them why you
think that way about it
that's it tell them why you think that
way about it remember stand up is how
your world collides with the rest of the
[__] world
so if you don't like walking the street
in the middle just [__] talk about it
and that's it and that's that
[__] it's monday i'm [__]
excited i'm excited fourth of july is
over with i'm done with the birth tour
we are making up that september 2nd date
in mississippi so don't throw away your
[__] tickets
and that's it and that's that this week
i got no shows that i know of i might
pick something up i'm supposed to go
with ari tonight to a bruce lee movie in
the [__] city
uh he's gonna have some mushrooms i'm
gonna bring some [__] abx's
and we're gonna [__] take it from
there but that's it and that's that
i love you [__] with all my
heart stay black
uncle joey loves you and here's for a
word for my sponsors
all right you savages thank you
we're back and we're ready to rock i'll
have more dates for you soon but anyway
before we go
now for a word from our sponsor
better help listen if you're thinking
about therapy this pandemic beat us all
up
this pandemic destroyed us our mind how
we thought our insecurities
we spent a lot of time alone and that's
not good for anybody eating right
working out
and getting plenty of sleep they're all
a good start to being there but there's
no substitute
for therapy especially talk therapy
better help makes online therapy
accessible convenient and affordable
listen if you turn on one of these
podcasts from last year you could see i
was struggling mentally ever since i
contacted dana last april it's been a
great year for me
why is therapy important because
you need it listen even sean mendes is
canceling three weeks of his tour
because life gets overwhelming
it's important and better help is online
therapy that offers video phone and chat
you can choose not to see anyone on
camera if you want to it's much more
affordable than in person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
48 hours if you've been looking it's
very hard to get a hold of a therapist
contact
betterhelp.com joey and i'm going to get
you 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com
joey
the joint is also brought to you by
expressvpn
the best if you're looking at something
you don't want people to know your
business
do you so if you're online and you're
using cookies and all that stuff people
know what you're looking at if you want
to look at little midgets in africa they
know you're looking at it who needs that
that's why you need express vpn
your internet provider sees every single
website you visit they'll sell you
information with expressvpn it puts a
stop to all this it creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet
expressvpn works on all devices phones
laptops
even routers so everyone who shares your
wi-fi can be protected i use expressvpn
on my phone
especially when i'm in the hotel wi-fi
you don't want people to need i'm saying
use expressvpn
is as easy as closing the bathroom door
just fire up the app click one button
and boom you're protected
mashable and the verge agree expressvpn
is the best vpn available if you believe
your online activities your business
visit expressvpn.com
joey again
that's expressvpn.com
joey
i want to thank expressvpn i want to
thank lucy.com
and i want to thank betterhelp but i
want to thank you guys
for [__] always having my back and
the support that you give me stay black
have a great week and we'll be back next
wed this wednesday
the 13th all right i love you
[__] have a great week and we'll
see you
wednesday
you